>> Laura: YOU ALL KNOW WE'VE
BEEN COVERING THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA FOR MONTHS
YET NOTHING SEEMS TO BE
IMPROVING DESPITE ALL THE MONEY
BEING THROWN AT THE PROBLEM.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT'S HAPPENING.
THE STATE LEADERSHIP IS FAILING
THE PEOPLE.
BUT CALIFORNIANS, WELL, I'VE GOT
TO TELL YOU THERE'S HOPE ON THE
HORIZON BECAUSE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS PREPARING A
SWEEPING PLAN TO GET THE
HOMELESS OFF THE STREETS OF
LOS ANGELES AND OTHER CITIES.
IT'S ALL PART OF THE PRESIDENT'S
PUSH TO RENEW URBAN AMERICA.
IT'S MUSIC TO OUR EARS AND EVEN
PLACES BY THE WAY THAT DIDN'T
VOTE FOR HIM.
HE'S THE PRESIDENT OF ALL THE
PEOPLE, RIGHT?
HERE WITH ME NOW FOR MORE ON
THIS AND OTHER INTERESTING STUFF
HAPPENING AT THE WHITE HOUSE, IT
GOT NO COVERAGE.
BEN CARSON, SECRETARY OF HOUSING
AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT.
DR. CARSON, CAN YOU TELL US
ABOUT WHAT THE PRESIDENT'S
PASSION IS AND WHAT IS HIS
ULTIMATE GOAL.
SPEAK WITH HAD MULTIPLE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
HOMELESSNESS SITUATION.
IT SEEMS TO BE WORSE IN PLACES
WHERE THERE IS A LOT OF
REGULATORY BARRIERS, AND
CALIFORNIA AS A POSTER CHILD FOR
THAT.
IF YOU GO OUT THERE AND YOU SEE
SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE ON THE
STREET AND YOU TALK TO THEM,
MANY OF THEM SIMPLY ARE NOT
CAPABLE OF TAKING CARE OF
THEMSELVES AND WE HAVE TO TAKE
SOME RESPONSIBILITY HERE.
GENERALLY IT'S THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE LOCALITY,
THE CITY, THE MUNICIPALITY, TO
TAKE CARE OF PEOPLE.
BUT IF THAT'S NOT HAPPENING, IT
DEVOLVES TO ANOTHER LEVEL.
IF THE CITY AND THE STATE ARE
NOT TAKING CARE, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS GOT TO DO
SOMETHING.
THE PRESIDENT IS VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT DOING SOMETHING.
>> Laura: EVEN IN PLACES WHERE
THEY DON'T SUPPORT HIM, DIDN'T
VOTE FOR HIM, PROBABLY WON'T
VOTE FOR HIM.
>> HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THAT.
HE LOOKS AT THESE PEOPLE AND
RECOGNIZES.
>> Laura: THEY ARE
HUMAN BEINGS.
>> WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
TAKE CARE OF THEM.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE WON'T WORK
WITH THE LOCALITIES AND I DON'T
WANT TO SAY SPECIFICALLY WHAT'S
GOING TO BE DONE BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT TO GET AHEAD OF IT.
OBVIOUSLY WE CAN'T JUST LEAVE
PEOPLE IN THOSE SITUATIONS.
>> Laura: ERIC GARCETTI, THE
DEMOCRAT, HE WELCOMED A FEDERAL
DELEGATION.
SAYING WE ARE JUST LEARNING
ABOUT THIS IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL."
A FEDERAL DELEGATION, MY EARRING
JUST FELL OFF.
IT'S LIVE TV SO I'LL PUT A
BACKWALL I'M TALKING.
THIS IS WHAT WE WOMEN DO.
A FEDERAL DELEGATION WAS THERE
AND HE SAID HE WELCOMED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT'S THE CATCH.
THEY'RE PLANNING $1.75 BILLION
IN THEIR BUDGET IN JUNE AND THEY
WANT SOME HELP I WOULD IMAGINE
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT
ARE YOU GOING TO KEEP ADVOCATING
THAT WE POUR MONEY INTO
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT REAL CHANGES
TO HOW THEY DEAL WITH THE
HOMELESS PROBLEM?
STICKER THAT'S THE DEFINITION OF
CRAZINESS.
DURING THE SAME THING OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AND EXPECTING A
DIFFERENT RESULT.
WHAT WE REALLY HAVE TO DO IS GET
TO THE ROOT CAUSE OF THE
HOMELESSNESS SITUATION AND DEAL
WITH IT.
AS I'VE SAID BEFORE, TOKYO WHICH
HAS MORE PEOPLE TO
NEW YORK CITY, HAS NO
HOMELESSNESS.
ONE OF THE LEFT-WING
ORGANIZATIONS CAME OUT AND
CARSON SAID THERE IS NO
HOMELESSNESS BUT THEY FOUND TWO
PEOPLE WHO WERE HOMELESS.
WE HAVE TO BE SERIOUS ABOUT
DEALING WITH THESE PROBLEMS AND
IT CAN BE DONE.
IT'S A MATTER OF TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE TREMENDOUS
TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE, REMOVING THE
BARRIERS.
>> Laura: RIGHT NOW THEY CAN'T
CLEAR UP LEGAL OUTLETS THEY HAVE
A PLACE TO PUT THEM.
THERE IS A LOT MORE THAT WE
DON'T A TIME TO GET INTO.
I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TODAY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THIS IS REALLY EXCITING BECAUSE
WE HAVE THE PRESIDENT GOING
FORWARD AGAIN, GETTING VERY
LITTLE COVERAGE IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, ON THE
HISTORICALLY BLACK COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN THE FAITH-BASED
BAN ON ANY FEDERAL FUNDING.
WHAT DID HE DO?
>> ONE OF THE FIRST EXECUTIVE
ORDERS HE SIGNED WAS
TRANSFERRING THE HISTORICALLY
BLACK COLLEGES --
TO SHOW YOU THE PRIORITY.
HE'S ASKED THE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES TO DO    DO WHAT THEY C
AGENCIES TO DO    DO WHAT THEY N
AGENCIES TO DO    DO WHAT THEY T
AGENCIES TO DO    DO WHAT THEY O
HELP WITH THE UNIVERSITIES.
THERE WERE PROBABLY 500 OR 600
PEOPLE IN THAT ROOM.
DO YOU THINK YOU WILL HEAR THAT
STORY?
THERE'S A LOT OF NEWS OUTLETS.
DO YOU THINK YOU WILL HEAR THAT
STORY?
OF COURSE NOT.
>> Laura: HOLLYWOOD
CELEBRITIES WILL SAY HE DOESN'T
CARE ABOUT BLACK PEOPLE.
IT'S THE CONSTANT REFRAIN AND
THEY ARE SAYING IT,
SECRETARY CARSON, I THINK
THEY'RE REALLY AFRAID OF THE
NEEDLE MOVING EVEN A LITTLE BIT
AND TRUMPS DIRECTION IN 2020.
HE'S NOT DOING THIS BECAUSE OF
THAT BECAUSE HE WAS DOING STUFF
THAT WAS REALLY POSITIVE AND
GREAT RESULTS FOR THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY
BEFORE THIS BUT THIS IS JUST ONE
MORE MEASUREMENT OF HIS
COMMITMENT.
>> I THINK PEOPLE WILL BEGIN TO
RECOGNIZE WHAT'S GOING ON.
IT'S NOT ABOUT DEMOCRATS OR
REPUBLICANS.
IT'S ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND THE FACT
THAT THE RISING TIDE LIFTS ALL
BOATS AND THIS IS THE WAY IT'S
THOUGHT ABOUT.
THAT'S WHY IT'S WORKING.
>> Laura: LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT
EVER FOR BLACK AMERICA.
>> EVEN LOWER IN THE LAST
ANALYSIS.
>> Laura: ARE YOU HAVING FUN?
ALL THINGS CONSIDERED, WOULD YOU
RATHER BE DOING BRAIN SURGERY?